[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now this is a segment where viewers try
to find mistakes on our show so far many
challengers no winners
people have tried we are flawless mm-hmm
never made a mistake like a diamond yeah
sometimes reply but anyway tonight a fan
with the YouTube handle on the highway
to hell 9 says he thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened during a
recent comedy sketch when I was showing
new Barbie dolls based on popular movies
take a look so I found a mistake that
you said while you were talking about
your Barbie dolls you made a statement
how the doll was coming from The Dark
Knight rising movie that's coming out in
July
hey from the new movie from the new
Batman movie Dark Knight rising it's
Bane barb everyone loves me it's not
rising it's Dark Knight Rises you were
right about the coming out in July but
it's rises not rising
sorry Conan but I think I got you this
time
no better advertisement for Ithaca
College than to shoot the hanger in your
laundry hamper
and when I see that face I think that
dude is on the highway to hell
way the hell nah watch out but before I
get on the highway to hell to the
laundry closet sorry on the highway to
hell 9 but you screwed up and you
screwed up big-time you assumed I was
talking about the Dark Knight Rises the
new blockbuster Batman movie wrong you
should have been paying attention I was
talking about the Dark Knight rising the
new adult film based on the
[Applause]
that's what I was doing in fact here's a
clip
Batman what's that Commissioner hard-on
you say the Riddler's on the loose don't
worry when I catch him I'll make sure he
does plenty of hard
babe did you order a pizza yes I'm very
hungry from fighting cry well I hope you
like your pizza with extra sausage
bang the Riddler
hello Batman how did you find my secret
Batcave
never mind bad jerk riddle me this yes
how many ways are there to please the
Riddler three way
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much I'm very proud well
the challenge still stands if you think
you spotted an error on our show
reported team koco.com / how I find an
error we will sort it out right here on
the air let's see if you've got what it
takes to make chunk meat out of the
maestro